es gibt einen neuen mega spannenden fund
zu den ninja einen 300 jahre alten ninja
er tatsächlich etwas licht in die ganze
sache bringen den ja das sind schwarz
gekleidete und gut ausgebildete kämpfer
aus japan
die vor allem spionierten und angriffe
verübt die mysteriöse kunst der ligna
ist heute fast ausgestorben und wirklich
viel was man nicht über sie was das
dokument alles über die ninja verrät
jetzt klick zum science fiction da
gibt's täglich spannende science videos
abonnieren kann nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
abgesehen von einigen geheimen leer
texten für ninja die wohl ab dem 17
jahrhundert entstanden sind gibt es kaum
verlässliche historische quellen zum
mysteriösen leben der sagenumwobenen
kampfkünstler da die meisten
informationen zu den ninja mündlich
überliefert worden sind weiß die
fachwelt sehr wenig über sie ganz im
gegensatz zu den samurai doch jetzt hat
ein japanisches forschungsteam einen 300
jahre alte night entdeckt der insgesamt
sechs versprechen enthält unterschrieben
wurde das streng geheime dokument von
einem ninja namens in syke geht so der
kämpfer schwört sein wissen in jedem
fall für sich zu behalten und isny
weiterzugeben andernfalls so hält kids
so in dem ein festnehme es zur strafe
mit allen göttern von mehr als 60
japanischen provinzen auf konkret geht
es um das wissen bezüglich der spionage
und sabotage fähigkeit wieder ninja
diese künste streng geheim zu halten war
den kriegern also alles was wichtig wie
das aktuelle dokument jetzt beweist dazu
der japanische forscher yoshiki kakao
von einem japanischen ninja
forschungszentrum im prinzip kann man
ihn ja mit diesem vergleichen sie
brachen in fremde häuser ein
der große unterschied zwischen beiden
war jedoch dass ninja eine moral hatten
und einen kodex an den sie sich hielten
in der heutigen zeit also vielleicht
vergleichbar mit geheimdiensten die
informationen sammeln und sich um die
sicherheit kümmern ninja also quasi als
staatsbedienstete mit dieser besonderen
aufgabe zudem dank geht so seine meister
in dem dokument dafür dass dieser ihm
die kunst des new zoo also die ninja
kunst beigebracht hat in comics und
filmen werden den ninja auf mit einer
bestimmten kampfkunst in verbindung
gebracht doch die ninja kriegskunst
nimmt so ist
vielmehr auf spionage und strategische
angriffe spezialisiert hierbei ging es
also viel mehr darum informationen zu
sammeln ohne dabei entdeckt zu werden an
der nutzung von waffen war den ninja
laut vieler experten und expertinnen
dagegen nicht wirklich gelegen der jetzt
entdeckte gehört zu insgesamt 130
dokumenten die die kids familie einst
ein ninja kyoto der japanischen mie
universität vor kurzem gespendet hatte
diese hat das ziel dass linda
vermächtnis nachzubilden
der eid wurde wahrscheinlich nach kitz
tod an seiner angehörigen geschickt die
experten und expertinnen stießen
außerdem auf ein weiteres höchst
spannendes schriftstück ein gelöbnis das
beweist dass die geheime bansen shuhei
aus dem 17ten jahrhundert tatsächlich
genutzt wurde oft wird sie auch als
enzyklopädie der ninja bezeichnet denn
sie enthält strategien und taktiken der
kämpfer der großteil ihres inhaltes ist
allerdings unbekannt und auch ihre
tatsächliche nutzung konnte bisher nie
nachgewiesen werden für die ninja
forschung ist das also eine mehr als
spektakuläre entdeckung ich bin ja mal
gespannt ob die forschungsergebnisse in
neue ninja filme einfließen werden oder
ob sie daraufhin sogar produziert werden
und jetzt von hinten durch die brust ins
auge
neben ninja film gibt es ja auch
horrorfilme im kino und auf dem computer
kann man horror games zocken unbedingt
ansehen also hier anklicken horror games
die horror psychologie hinter dem psycho
games bei der animo dem gaming
psychologen den natürlich abonnieren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran